Well, let's see. Let's convert this velocity to meters per second.
When we do this conversion, we get a speed of 3890 m/s.
I know β is just v/c where c is the speed of light 310⁸m/s
and when I carry this out, I get a value of 1.310⁻⁵.
So actually a very small fraction of the speed of light and actually this leads us
to a gamma of 1.000000000084, barely larger than 1 but large enough.
These machines are so sensitive that this actually makes a difference and in fact,
they pretty quickly accumulate errors if you don't correct for special relativity.
Now, the engineers who designed these aren't so certain.
They don't want to gamble entirely on special relativity being true so they had an option--
special relativity mode on or off.
Einstein would be pleased to know that the special relativity mode
is still very much on for the GPS satellites.